quattro anni fa ho visitato il perito
moreno un imponente ghiacciaio della
patagonia argentina
chiesi ai miei accompagnatori notizie
sullo stato di salute di questo
ghiacciai è ben consapevole che nelle
nostre parti nelle nostre alpi ghiacciai
si ritirano a causa del riscaldamento
globale
ebbene vi dissero che il perito moreno
era in buona salute con i suoi cicli di
scongelamento e ricongelamento estivo
invernale riuscivo a mantenere il suo
fronte anzi veniva dato in avanzamento
quindi ero abbastanza tranquillo poi lo
scorso anno nel 2017 uno studio i
giapponesi dimostrò che invece
confrontando i dati sperimentali attuali
con quelli dei decenni precedenti la
temperatura delle acque del lago su cui
il ghiacciaio d'estate riversa i suoi
ghiacci quando si scioglie favore
aumentando con una velocità di 30 volte
superiore rispetto ai decenni precedenti
e quindi anche il perito moreno è
influenzato dal riscaldamento globale e
questo di certo non è una buona cosa
e veniamo al teatro sociale dove siamo
oggi 1968 la foto non è del 1968 ma ne è
di un tè degli anni precedenti
bene nel 1968 anno molto importante per
trento molto significativo
lo ricordo bene ricordo di aver
calpestato per la prima volta i legni di
questo palco mi sono esibito con una
band di musicisti pop adolescenti
ricordo l'emozione più o meno come
quella di oggi
nonostante siano passati 50 anni e abbia
fatto decine e decine di convegni
internazionali in cui sono stato
relatore
ebbene nel 1968 il cosiddetto giorno del
debito ambientale cadeva cad circa la
fine dell'anno il 31 dicembre voleva
dire che in quell'anno in quel periodo
c'era un equilibrio tra risorse
consumate e risorse rinnovate da parte
del pianeta
c'era un equilibrio tra produzione e
alla sostenibilità ambientale
ebbene dopo 50 anni quest'anno quel
giorno è caduto il primo di agosto
quindi vuol dire che il valdone di
agosto
noi abbiamo cominciato a usare o le
risorse del 2019
oppure le risorse di un altro pianeta
che per ora non siamo stati ancora
capaci di colonizzare perlomeno dal
punto di vista agricolo
quindi tra i settori economici che sono
responsabili di questo cambiamento di
questo utilizzo di risorse circa un
quarto è ascrivibile all'agricoltura al
settore forestale della produzione del
cibo
secondo solamente al termico ed
elettrico superiore a quello industriale
se consideriamo poi che si prevede che
il 2050 avremo 9 miliardi e 6 di
popolazione due miliardi e mezzo di più
di quello che siamo ora
già con le problematiche che abbiamo ora
ma soprattutto ci sarà anche un
urbanizzazione maggiore quindi una
minore capacità di accedere al cibo
locale
altro importante fattore sarà questo
dell'incremento della classe media
soprattutto nei paesi in via di sviluppo
chiaramente avremo una aumentata
capacità di spesa che vorrà dire cercare
cime più buoni ma non vuol dire solo
andare a cercare il vino italiano il
parmigiano reggiano o prodotti di
qualità ma ora deve avere una dieta
globalmente più ricca più ricca di
proteine soprattutto animali e vuol dire
quindi più carne quindi se andiamo a
vedere l'evoluzione prevista tra la
linea blu che è la crescita demografica
e le barre che sono la crescita della
quantità di carne consumata si break si
prevede per unità di popolazione qui
abbiamo milioni di tonnellate di carne
per miliardo di persone
vedremo come quantitativamente in senso
lato la quantità di richiesta di carne
sarà molto superiore a quella che è
proporzionalmente l'aumento demografico
quindi più che proporzionale ovviamente
differenziato tra diverse tipologie di
specie
quindi la prima parola chiave è onnivoro
nuovo velivolo e rimarrà onnivoro anche
se ci sono minoranze che si possono
essere considerato in crescita di
popolazione che decidono assolutamente
di eliminare gli amenti gli alimenti di
origine animale o le carni dalla loro
alimentazione
d'altra parte della tener conto che
circa 75 per sempre delle terre
coltivate in modo indiretto diretto
servono per alimentare e produrre gli
animali e quindi i prodotti di origine
animale che non ha una quantità
veramente incredibile dovrebbe aumentare
ancora il 18 per cento delle emissioni
globali è dovuto proprio a tutto ciò che
sta intorno alla produzione animale
il proposito del 5 per cento della
produzione antropica diciamo ma
globalmente della terra 18 per sempre
quindi se andiamo a vedere l'impatto
delle diverse categorie di fonte
alimentare per unità di nutritivo in
questo caso di portarsi nutrizionale
delle kg delle proteine a vediamo come
la carne rossa illuminanti hanno un
impatto enorme con una quota di
conversione diciamo noi bassissima
mentre altre fonti proteiche sono
estremamente più sostenibili a partire
da qualche fonte proteica animali tipo
il latte o le uova ma poi soprattutto i
vegetali e altre componenti di quelle
che vengono chiamate proteine e
sostenibili alternative come gli sette
gli archi lo diceva già uno speaker
precedenti il presentatore precedente
l'aveva già accennato questa cosa la
diremo ancora quindi tutto questo è
stato un allarme che la fa nei suoi vari
rapporti degli ultimi dieci anni ha
voluto lanciare soprattutto questo che
vedete la copertina di questo rapporto
detto chiaramente che questa situazione
è insostenibile per il futuro del
pianeta soprattutto relativamente al
fatto che punto ruminanti emissioni
grande spreco di risorse e di gas serra
di questo ho avuto la fortuna di poterlo
portare a parlare proprio sabato scorso
con graziano da silva che il direttore
generale della fao lo vedete che da quel
momento in avanti la richiesta di
informazioni su internet ho fatto una
semplice ricerca con google search dei
vegani vegetariani aumentata enormemente
e non solo per motivi ideologici etici
ma proprio per motivi ambientali
quindi dobbiamo fare qualcosa dobbiamo
agire così non si può andare avanti
primo luogo dobbiamo sicuramente
garantire la sicurezza è il cibo
l'accesso al cibo di tutte queste
persone contemporaneamente noi
scienziati i genetisti agronomi
ingegneri diamo un nostro lavoro per
poter aumentare le rese aumentare le
rese sostenibili come si disse fare
questo quello che diciamo
l'intensificazione sostenibili delle
produzioni quindi aumentare le
efficienze produttive aumentare la
capacità che hanno piantagioni animali
di potersi rapportare quei cambiamenti
climatici inaridimento di terreni e poi
ridurre le emissioni terza cosa lo
sapete bene e dobbiamo ridurre le
perdite e sprechi perché lungo la catena
è dalla parte fino a partire dalla
produzione primaria conservazione
trasformazione logistica fino al consumo
del del prodotto nel piatto far con
l'eccesso del consumo finale o in
eccesso delle porzioni del consumo
finale compongono una porta e criticità
ma quello che possiamo fare noi come
cittadini consumatori è sicuramente
riequilibrare quella che è la nostra
scelta alimentare verso una dieta più
sostenibile e qui abbiamo possibili
scenari che vanno oltre il convenzionale
what anti deficit
[Musica]
che c'entra pesante bene questo filmato
delle sorelle burley sana e madre né
firmato oggi un progetto di tesi di
laurea in design è molto ispirato realtà
è fatto benissimo il primo scenario è
quello di andare a non cambiare nulla
non modificare niente e quindi andare
verso una situazione abbastanza
grammatica di cambiamento climatico di
più nel partito o di inquinamento molto
elevato e veramente catastrofico gli
esaltati siamo da vento in questo
scenario qui è quello che è stato detto
da molti bellas artes aveva chiaramente
una una evidenza il secondo scenario del
fare molto più interessante dal nostro
punto di vista di tecnologie alimentari
o di ricercatore in questo campo è
l'alternativa vegetale alle proteine
animali ma dando la stessa sensorialità
delle proteine animali quindi della
carne
qui vediamo due hamburger e che sono in
tutto e per tutto simili al voto carne
nel mondo in italia che provengono dalla
essenzialmente dalla utilizzo delle
proteine della del pisello oppure
quest'altro hamburger ancora più simile
alla carne e che è interessante perché è
una molecola particolare che è
un'emoglobina una monetina che è
prodotta dal punto di vista biotech a
partire dalla dalle proteine della soia
è come se noi avessimo un sangue che non
ha sangue un sangue che non proviene
dall affermazione ma che non si proviene
dalla utilizzo biotecnologico della
della proteina di soia e questo rende in
cultura il prodotto di consistenza di
succosità e di aroma e di colore molto
simile è la carne alla carne real e
l'altro pure la chiave qui però è una
parola tecnologica e testurizzazione
perché per far questo dobbiamo far sì
che il nostro analoga ma la nostra
analogo ma non sto formulato debba
diventare poi un prodotto simile dal
punto di vista della struttura alla
fibra muscolare
altri esempi sono di queste tipologie
fornaci che provengono
nella fermentazione di frutta secca
oleosa come le arachidi o gli anacardi
oppure altri in pasticche infatti di
cottura si comportano come dei salumi
addirittura a pisa tutta vegetale il
terzo scenario è quello di produrre
carne laboratorio
bene al di là di questa visione un po
fantascientifica per sorelle berlin
siamo già nelle condizioni di poterlo
fare questo ci sono delle start up molto
evolute dal punto di vista baio tech che
sono in grado anche grazie al fatto del
giorno del fortissimo investitori legati
alla sostenibilità ambientale 2 per
tutti di caprio e bill gates che
sponsorizzano questo tipo di di di start
up da una cellula di male poter avere
quindi poi attraverso di bioreattori
delle linee cellulari che vengono poi
ristrutturate impalcato come fossero
delle carni vere e proprie è una carne
vera proveniente da animale ma non
ammirare allevato e macellato venne
chiamata carne pulito carne sintetica ma
la settimana scorsa c'è un'agenzia
alimentare americana ha promulgato una
norma che consente la
commercializzazione di questo prodotto
che si pensa però non avverrà prima del
andiamo al parto scenario quello di
allevare per l'appunto insetti o micro
ebbe a mitraglia come cibo sfruttando
gli oceani e sfruttando il fatto che gli
stati possono svilupparsi essere
allevati su una quota estremamente
piccola di suolo e quindi poter avere
un'efficienza molto molto elevata non
tanto per avere la cavalletta di cui
parlava il nostro il nostro presentatore
oppure avere
i villi fritti viola o la zuppa di larve
che quello lo lasciamo dire agli
orientali che nella loro tradizione
gastronomica ma è vero dei componenti
che possono arricchire una produzione
tra virgolette normali che abbiamo due
esempi provenienti dal dalla creatività
dei nostri studenti di formulazioni
alimentare ei vari la farina di legno
utilizzata per fare i biscotti oppure la
spirulina utilizzata per fare delle
tagliatelle arriviamo il quinto scenario
è quello che mi piace di più dal punto
di vista del cittadino consumatore con
una parola chiave italiani e volgere
consumare meno carne in maniera
consapevole
possibilmente carne locale e quindi vuol
dire non rinunciare alla fiorentina il
carrè di maiale alla radio sarà tutto
volete citato la luganega a usarne un po
meno e tutte le volte che la mangiamo
renderci conto che stiamo facendo una
cosa che per l'ambiente non è
esattamente il massimo e quindi poteva
eventualmente sostituire con prodotti
non convenzionali
questa tendenza c'è già scesa intorno al
20 30 per cento in molti paesi in cui si
convince a monitorare questa riduzione
di consumo di carne questo è piuttosto
interessante e quindi in questa
condizione possiamo dire che non
rinunciano la carne rimaniamo anni morì
e questo è importante perché io voglio
rimanere e quindi abbiamo tutte le i
vantaggi da più di vista nutrizionale
del mangiare proteine ad altissimo
valore biologico però
possiamo fare qualcosa per l'ambiente
quindi qui ci sono i leoni i leoni noi
ricercatori noi scienziati che stiamo
cercando di far sì che questa
intensificazione sostenibile possa
realmente essere realizzata questa è una
grandissima scommessa ma come cittadini
i consumatori devono rendersi conto che
anche attraverso il cibo possiamo dare
un contributo al futuro del pianeta
noi da parte nostra lo facciamo io cerco
di farlo ma questa è una cosa che
un'azione contraria perché ad essere
fatta anche da parte di ognuno di voi
grazie